So the final step is actually run minor. I can just press next here and we are on this page
Yeah, we will do it using
tmux what is tmux is the
special special application on the
Linux that allow you to run your scripts on the background
Since for example if I will run some script
Just as it is here. For example, I don't know Python
script
by
Like I will press run it will run for a while. But when I close this window, it will stop
It will close as well and the script will stop to work. So this is why we use tmux tmux is allow us to
Make this script run on the background since so
Therefore if we close this window, it will still continue to work
As long as the virtual machine deployed on the Google Cloud platform, so I will just copy this command
Paste it here. Okay. Yeah, don't forget that you need to activate your virtual environment source
Okay, yeah, we can see that here is the dot
And
We can also update the moving average model if you want how to do it. We can just
put list go to CD neurons
List here and make nano
minor dot 5 and
We just can update
Number here. Let's update it from 12 to
24 so we will fetch moving average data for the last two hours since the one time
Frame is five minutes. Press it ctrl x to save
press
Yes, and
Press enter here. Okay, we updated it and our next step
Is just run this command. Let's try it
Here and I press let's copy paste this comment press enter
Okay, yeah, so if we updated it
we need to
Go back to the folder
Into the main folder where we can
Run this script really so how to go to get back. It's like CD
Dot-dot and we go one level above so as you can see here before we was at bit bridge
neurons
directory and now
We are at bit bridge directory itself. So we need to run this script in the bit bridge directory
I can use arrows arrow up arrow up arrow up and
Here is the command that I paste previously
They say common same comment that is it is here and let me press enter
Now should magic. Yeah now we can see logs
That the miner is trying to deploy
So as we can see here, there's some exon exon means server server got deployed on this IP and the address and
The miner running is the good sign. We can see that the miner got deployed on to the subnet number one eight three
Here is the minor
credentials
This is good news
Okay, I will take a pause here
But in several minutes usually from five to ten
You will see sorry
You will see the logs like this
You will see logs like this. You will see success log and you will see
How miner is making a prediction for the validator request really?
Okay, I will take a pause here
Yeah, I think this is it you have now you can just
Bravely
Close this window just like close it and it will work on the back end without your interaction
Yeah, if you can DHH from team accession
You can you need to use control B plus D. So I press control
B release and D. Okay. Now I'm just I can do whatever I want here
But we can see that using them
This command
Yeah, Teambox LS means least command that there is one minor window that is currently running and we can attach back to it
Aim attach
Yes, and
In five or ten minutes, you will see the logs with the successes and yeah, this is it for now
Thank you for watching and
Yeah, we can see the success logs here. Yeah
Don't be surprised with this error it's fine
Some logs just some logs so we can see success the minor was
Asked by a validator to make a predictions and using the moving average of the most recent energy data
It predicted that for the next five minutes
The energy demand going to be this one. How cool is that?
Now you can say
Everyone that you are successfully deployed prediction model on to that decentralized AI network
That's cool. So in this small assignment you actually
Use the Google Cloud Platform you actually use the decentralized AI network the blockchain itself and also predictive model
And as well as Linux, right?
And I think I I forgot something
Hundred percent, but you touched a lot of things
This is very cool. Okay. Thanks everybody for watching and
Enjoy the rest of your day